hey I'm Jessie thanks for tuning in for
the second day of the Wolfram tech
conference 2017 for those that are just
kind of tuning in I'm just here with
developers and other interesting people
using our technology and cool fun ways
I'm here with ila and she's gonna tell
us a little bit about what she does here
at the company and what she's doing here
at the Wolfram tech conference in
particular so hello yes so my name is
Ida I'm actually a manager and when we
search the department is called quality
analysis and we handle all sorts of
feedback about WolframAlpha that is not
what i'm actually at the country before
so the my conference participation is a
talk that I'm giving tomorrow with
another developer we work together on a
project that was that is it's a
sponsorship project for the local
marathon here because I love to run a
lot of people at the company really
really love to run um all the time I
mean and so I've started doing longer
distances in 2014 and one of the
marathons I've run since then was in
Chicago in 2015 and you know I come back
after the race go back to work and we
started talking about the race and my
manager was like so how many people
participate in my god close to 40,000
you know and I'm like it's a great deal
of data you know so we got all the data
for Chicago we turned it into a data set
for us readable an entity store and then
in 2016 I wrote a blog post all about
that race and we looked at you know not
just the individual runners but the
field of runners where does everyone
come from and how did the race progress
for all of them for example we had all
the data in there you know the location
and and pace at which people were going
so drilling down we could even identify
like you know these two people but we're
running together you know they're
probably related or you know there are
groups where
you have a disabled runner who has to
run with someone else to guide them and
so those were really it was just it was
a giant fun project and for this blog
post we also built an animation that
sort of shows the field of runner I
stood it at a given point in time we
show how many runners are at a certain
location along the racecourse so yeah so
this datasets huge so how exactly did
you get the status ID in and like
cleaned it up it's it's all available
online so if you participate in a race
after the race you can you know
typically go to the races homepage and
they will guide you to a result page and
based on a lot of them it's just you
know your first and last name or your
bib number you can then look up all you
know your starting time like its when
did you cross the start line and you get
all the little data points in between
Chicago is nicely they give your time
every five kilometer so there is a lot
of data points per person so you said it
came in raw like in a spreadsheet yeah
okay so how did that get turned into
what it is I know yes so um as you
mentioned it's just a spreadsheet so
it's just a bunch of strings and we had
to make them readable for us so we would
take locations for example so if someone
specified that they flew in from Boston
we would just take Boston and align it
with a city data entity that is then for
us computable so and we did this with
you know all the like cities states
countries with ages genders you know
things like that and so when they're in
the entity store there's like other
pieces of information attached to an
entity value is is that why these are
that's yes that's correct so we fast
forward a year and let's go to Champaign
we after we've done this for Chicago we
took up a conversation with the local
race administration then and they really
liked the idea that we're doing
something
the it's sort of you know they're not
the big name they're not New York
they're not Boston but it you know we
can provide them with a little something
that sets them apart from other big
races and for champagne we're building
the same animation by a lot of graphical
output and one piece for example is
whether or not a person qualified for
Boston if they got a Boston qualifier in
and so this information for example we
can now we did sort of begin to the
entity stores so I have a data set and
you know I can say you know this person
age 52
male gender you know I can now look up
his division I can look up you know this
was the requirement for him to qualify
for Boston so yes there's a lot of stuff
that we were able to throw in that you
know makes for easy computation cool um
so you mentioned that there is a
visualization that's sociated with
Chicago yes what was in it yes and you
know so on marathon Viacom it still
redirects to the 2016 animation for for
champagne and so what you can see here
is what I was trying to describe the
purple wave the height of the purple
wave indicates a certain number of
runners per I think it's a half a
kilometer that are you know in that area
we also pre generated the position dots
for the male and female winners green
and yellow we also added the median of
all runners and the center of gravity
just for the heck of it this is because
we can and we like it and so for this
animation is now of course interesting
to find out how you yourself did and
let's so so I'm
Runner and four other non runners out
there so the bib number is a unique
number assigned to you so I my bib
number in 2016 because I've done it so
often was 736 so at the number and we
will start the animation again and it'll
tell you down in the legend you can see
the I'm the light blue one so I'm at
least keeping up with a median I am of
Krishna we're near the winners I did not
start to win any money there was not the
plan but yes so we can show you it's
actually I always told people this is a
great way for people who watch the
marathon to check out when they should
be where you know like it because it
tells you when the masses are coming by
your neighborhood basically you know so
if you're traveling spectator it'd be an
optimized way to you know be like okay
this reminds me of like football play by
play like they have like the people like
the players and they're all like on the
field but like the yes yes and can you
put in more than one yes I believe we
cut it off at five it's at that point if
you want to see how you compare it to
other people maybe people you ran with
it's typically it's fairly difficult to
stay with a person so we thought you're
not going to compare yourself to more
than five but let's assume my running
partner he ran his thirteenth marathon
with the 666 as his bib number and so he
was a little concerned you didn't know
if he did not much he did not but so
there are there's the two of us I have
to scroll down and so then he has
another light dot there so what did you
say again the purple waves were the
purple waves always shows the the height
of the purple way wave shows the number
of runners at this at this location so
you can see at the very end you know
we start together I mean there's a wave
start but it's fairly concentrated you
know and then as the race progresses of
course the faster ones they're off the
course much quicker whereas the the slow
ones they take a much longer time along
the race course so that's why the wave
flattens out so and then you know at
some point everyone makes it into the
finish so were you able to figure out
any or ask any interesting questions
about these kind of weird concentrations
of runners in certain areas um yes so
not necessarily based on this animation
but based on the entity store that we
generated so we for example as I said in
Chicago has a lot of split information
so every 5 kilometers that's really nice
and so we were looking at you know how
many how much time does it take a person
to get to a certain split and you know
you have you have your histogram with
certain you know you always see when the
mass of people comes through you know at
five kilometers and when the mass of
people's at ten kilometers and we saw
for example in those graphs before the
before the big spike there was always a
tiny spike always just before the big
wave and we looked into it and those who
are always the runners that try to beat
the four hours which is it's like this
you know you have you elite runners they
start to make money they start to win
money I am NOT one of those who a lot of
people which is pure survival is at the
top of the list right just making it
through maybe get your Boston qualifier
and get a PR but a lot of people just
try to get below the four hours and
that's one for me always my fastest was
like just below the four and it was the
first marathon I've ever run and I've
never been able to beat it again it's
like I had you know a 359 or for two or
four six things like this so it's like
two minutes over 26 miles is so minor
and you think you can do it again but
it's actually it can be quite difficult
but these are things where you know we
visualize the field of runners and all
of a sudden it's like oh yes these are
harder for our runners like I am not the
only one
desperate to attempt this
you know so so yeah that's so cool um so
what else I know you're giving a talk
later today
what else are y'all going over in your
talk you and Jeff um so I will again I'm
I'm not a developer I just happen to be
lucky enough that I can combine my
personal with my professional life
because he left me you know play around
with this so Jeff is really gonna dive
into the coding that was done to make
this work I will give a you know
background information on the on the
Illinois Marathon how it has evolved as
a because it's a big community event
that brings in a lot of people a lot of
money it's just it's a really nice event
to be involved with I will in Champaign
you have to mention the weather I would
talk a little bit about the weather it's
just that it's weather weather makes a
huge difference but especially in
Champaign and I'm going to mention this
tomorrow as as well whatever the weather
it's never good you have too much of
whatever it is it's too much Sun or too
much rain you have too much snow too
much humidity it's you know it's it's
never it's not a very forgiving place
and in terms of the marathon this
marathon happens to be one of the few
that had to be canceled mid race and so
this is yes 2050s so marathons do get
canceled for various reasons but a lot
of times all most of the time it happens
before the event not while you have
thousands of runners on the course and
2015 it's just thunder storm decided to
stop I stick around we had a lot of
lightning strikes hit the ground and at
some point they just had to cancel it
which I was thankful for because I had a
horrible run and and I made it to I
think I was at Mile 18 and then
the cop cars came around like you guys
had done oh my god um thanks like in
first stuffing right it's off before
Kyla powers and good luck with your talk
later this afternoon or it was it's
tomorrow morning okay tomorrow morning
well good luck and like always if y'all
have questions leave them in the
comments below we can't get to it during
these live sessions but someone would be
able to get back to you later and check
out community Wolfram calm because
someone may have already had your
question and you can get your question
answered there for sure so thanks